you're in the architecture profession
and you want to create some amazing tick
tocks some reels Awesome YouTube shorts
well today I'm going to show you exactly
how you can do that using twin motion
what's going on guys my name is David
Thomas I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and today we'll
break down all of the settings and all
the presets you need to know to make
twin motion your best friend for social
media now let's turn around to this
screen and get started with today's
tutorial So today we're going to start
with our 3D rendered still images and
show you exactly how to convert them
into tick tock's reels or even YouTube
shorts we have the archad model open up
from the actual live project and we've
also got it open in Twin motion we're
going to start with some of our material
add-ons so we're going to work through
the marble the Timber and the floor
tiles and slowly put all the materials
on that we like this process doesn't
really matter it's completely up to you
guys so what I'm going to do is Skip
ahead and convert all of these materials
into twin motion or Mega scans materials
okay now that we have all of our
materials placed into twin motion next
and start to add a little bit of
furniture to give it a bit of Life
personally for me I jump into sketchfab
and use all of the furniture from here
rather than using twin motions
accessories because they just aren't as
good so now that we've added all of our
furniture back into this plan now we're
going to do a little bit of a lighting
overlay just to include some lights so
it isn't as flat and as boring as it
typically is into emotion now that we
have our lighting completed it's time to
move on to the most essential feature
and it is setting up the camera angle
and the video angle for your tick tocks
reels or shorts so if we come down to
our media down the bottom hit that video
icon tap create video it's going to take
you to Media mode what you want to do
then is come back out into our video go
to more go to format and change this
format so let's export it to 4K and what
we need to do is invert it the other way
around we're going to flip those two
numbers around and it's automatically
going to take it into a portrait shot
now obviously that is an ugly shot we
don't want to use that we want to then
once again again go into the actual
video press on more go to our camera
settings and adjust our focal length for
me personally I like a 50 millimeter
focal length because quite a natural
focal length we can go even more
compressed to 100 millimeters if you
really want to zoom in on the bits and
pieces that you like but for this let's
drop back down to a 50 millimeter let's
remove our vignetting let's remove our
lens flare and let's keep these two
settings off next we want to come back
into our video go back in some more and
we want to come into our lighting
personally I like to go into exposure
and turn auto exposure off so I have
full control of how I want this scene to
look for me personally I like it about
two two and a half maybe even three on
this so it's a nice dark Moody scene as
we're talking about this wine and this
kitchen in the morning sun I also like
to increase my ambient light up to one
just so all the colors come out crystal
clear and if you want to play with your
white balance as well you can so
personally 6-2 is a nice cool tone a 7-2
works for this environment because we
have a lot of Timber going on last but
not least you want to come into your
more settings again go into render turn
on path Trace turn on GI and adjust your
shadows if you have those options
available to you obviously I'm on a Mac
so I don't have path tracing available
on this computer to showcase the full
potential of twin motion but it is
enough to get us across the line to
start working with reels tick tocks and
shorts if you don't want to do any
post-production color grading what you
can also do is come back into your video
go to the more setting go to camera and
then go into your visual effects we want
to go to our color gradient and we can
adjust our contrast up and down here as
well as our saturation so if you want
this export to look slightly different
from everybody else's just play with
these until you're comfortable with the
actual Outlook you also have some
presets available to you in Twin motion
I personally don't like any of these I
personally don't use any of them but I
do adjust the contrast and the
saturation to suit what I'm trying to
create and for whatever reason and if
you want to create some cool filters and
effects you can jump into filters go to
the type and adjust it to how you see
fit maybe you want a cartoon sketch and
then transition into a realistic render
you can do that so easily in Twin motion
so now let's put a couple of these clips
together stitch them together export
them and show you guys the results
[Music]
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
the video if you did make sure you check
out the playlist the side of me if you
loved it make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below as well as
the like button for the YouTube
algorithm but like always I'll see you
next Monday